get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
where each week we ask three of our
writers to read their pieces out
we've got douglas marty who argues that
nothing is racist if everything is
racist
the reverend steve morris and why we
should bring back the british holiday
camp
and toby young on his new dating website
for
lockdown skeptics first douglas marty
hearing that
dawn butler mp had been pulled over by
the metropolitan police
i briefly hoped the taxpayer might get
back the whirlpool bath she charged us
on her parliamentary expenses
but the officers skipped the boot and
went straight to the passenger side
where they found the member for brent
central recording them with her phone
and looking pleased as punch to audition
as the new rosa parks as it happens
the footage she released showed the
police being deeply polite
and they subsequently explained that the
pullover had been due to a registration
plate mix-up
but butler claimed it was a case of the
dreaded
stop and search and within hours she was
on
channel 4 news being grilled by one of
their crack
interviewers fatima mangy
asked butler how such a thing could
happen to someone who a day earlier had
been
declared one of the 25 most
inspirational women in britain
by vogue magazine the questions
on channel 4 news seemed to have got
easier since i last went on
a smiling butler explained that this was
all par for the course
for an african caribbean woman
she then claimed that the met police is
institutionally racist
and that cressida dick should spend all
of her waking moments
trying to eradicate institutionally
racism from the met police
a day earlier a black teenager had been
macheted to death
in broad daylight in front of shoppers
on london's oxford street
three men aged 18 were arrested after
arriving at hospital with stab wounds of
their own
what normally happens at this stage is
that politicians and pundits debate the
utility of stop and search
some people say that stop and search
saves young black lives
others like dawn butler declare that
stop and search is racist
because it disproportionately targets
people of the racial background
who disproportionately do the stabbing
then the stabbing continues
i don't mind admitting that i am growing
tired of all the allegations
when butler tagged the met police as
institutionally racist
i noticed myself for the first time
vaguely
shrugging not because actual racism
isn't a horrible and
ugly thing but because the currency
appears to have been
inflated out of use over recent months
absolutely everything has been declared
racist
our entire history our whole society and
every white person in it
so allegations about the met have lost
the
pknc they once had meanwhile
news of just how racist and awful the uk
is
appears not to have spread across the
channel
between thursday and sunday 700 illegal
migrants
arrived in the uk by boat largely
courtesy of the uk border force
the authorities helped the people
smuggling networks
by meeting the migrants a little way out
in the channel assisting them off their
flimsy vessels
and depositing them safely on british
soil
where they can recover from the ordeal
that is france like
the debate over stop and search the
discussion of
what to do about law breaking on this
scale is
hobbled at the start because unless you
say
let in these tired and huddled masses
then you will be accused of racism
ponder out loud whether everyone from
the developing world who wishes to move
to the developed world is absolutely the
same as a jew fleeing nazi germany
and you will be accused of this same
appalling vice
as it happens a certain amount of vice
or at least vice signaling is good for
stopping illegal migration
when faced with a surge in illegal
migration earlier this decade
the australian government let it be
known that anyone trying to break into
the country
would see their boat repelled and spend
months on a lonely island
while the international media decried
this decision
attempts to break into australia dried
up
similarly in 2016 the danish parliament
voted in a law that made it possible to
take
valuables from an illegal migrant up to
the amount that their stay would cost
the danish taxpayer
they were howls from the foreign media
and while i don't know of even one case
where the law was enacted
it proved very helpful in sending a
message
in recent days some tories who wanted to
sound tough
have talked of sending in the royal navy
but on current performance that will
simply allow more british vessels
to pick up more migrants of the
thousands who have broken into britain
already this year
all are put up in hotels and other
accommodation at
taxpayers expense and no one not one
has been returned of course at this
stage people
tend to bow to the magisterium of the
law
but immigration law has become a charade
by law none of the recent arrivals
should be here
according to the dublin regulation
genuine asylum seekers ought to have
claimed asylum
in the first safe country they entered
by rights every arrival should be
returned to france
who should then return them to italy or
whichever country they came in from
who should return them to the country in
which they started
none of which happens it is a pretence
happily nodded along to by people who
think they can afford it
we have an asylum system which the
british public actually support
but we also now have this strange bonus
system where so long as you complete the
assault course and make it to kent
or the sea near it then you're in
the only way to stop the crossings would
be to let it be known
that everyone who tries to enter this
country illegally
will be returned having risked their
lives
and wasted their savings but
no politician will suggest it for the
same reason
that they fear discussing stop and
search and other policies
because to do so risks accusations of
racism
from insincere actors
personally i start to feel myself
getting past all this
when everything has become racist
then nothing is and the government
should ignore the critics and just do
whatever will stop the law breaking on
land
or sea that was douglas murray now
reverend steve morris by the 1980s
after decades of immense popularity the
great british holiday camp was in
terminal decline
the huge camps founded by billy butlin
and fred ponting
the chalets the dining hall the redcoats
in butlins
and blue coats pontins were becoming
passe
now the few that remain have been
rebranded as holiday villages
but why not bring them back surely old
fashioned camps had exactly what we need
today
simplicity gentle fun and a sense of
community
they were about team effort not atomized
nuclear families
above all perhaps they had a sense of
identity
and they were a real life changer for me
i recently came across an online video
of gunton hall
near lowestoft in the late 1970s
the film all 19 minutes of it was sheer
time travel
because there on the screen along with
hundreds of other campers
where my brother my dad and me
also recorded for posterity were the
canoe races
no life jackets only rekty vessels on a
deep lake
the donkey derbys with more hair raising
spills than the grand national
and the archery without adult
supervision
it's a wonder that we all survived
without serious injury
but we did possibly because
we'd learn to watch out for ourselves
there was a structure
to a week in the camp it wasn't simply
about lazing around
when people arrived they'd be split into
two houses
and for the rest of the week dozens of
activities
helped gain points for your house these
were done as a family with no individual
prices
after months locked up in our homes
don't we yearn
for a sense of shared endeavour again
for my parents the experience was
bittersweet
my dad had lost a very good job so the
overseas holidays went
together with the nice car and sharp
suits
we swapped five-star accommodation for
lower stuffed by the sea
but i preferred the camp it shaped who i
am
now holiday camps encourage
life skills my time in the donkey derby
built up not just riding abilities but
resilience
i spent more time falling off the thing
than i did on it
but as a result i went on to develop a
lifelong love of horses
what's more there was betting on the
outcome
my father and i spotted one particular
donkey that always
won despite the organizers changing his
number
and bib for every race we recognized his
markings
and made a decent return on our
investment
i grasped the importance of paying
attention and taking your chances
i think we all knew that we'd always
have to make
our own luck we also had cricket
coaching from a wonderful old gentleman
called harry
who stayed at the camp each day i would
be in the nets
brushing up on my forward defenses and
learning how to bowl
i got over my fear of the cricket ball
at cunton
and that was useful too however hard the
projectiles life
throws at you there's always a way of
avoiding them
every evening a band performed sometimes
we were offered the chance to get up and
sing a kind of
early karaoke this is why
later in life before i became a vicar i
spent years
trying to be a pop star plus
one night the main turn was the
marvellous bert whedon
author of the guitar tutorial guides
play in a day
which influenced the likes of paul
mccartney eric clapton
and brian may i remember listening to
bert and his beautiful guitar sound
and speaking to him afterwards his
advice was
never to give up and to keep practicing
one night a very ancient tommy trinder
did the cabaret
the ballroom was packed i think everyone
knew
trinder was well past his best i began
to doubt he'd still be breathing at the
end
but there he was wearing that old
battered hat
and whispering his catchphrase you lucky
people
we gave him a standing ovation
trinder was one of us and we weren't
going to make him feel bad
i learned something about grace
that has helped in my vocation as a
vicar
by the time i started going to holiday
camps with my wounded and financially
insecure family
such places were as much past their
prime
as tommy trinder and the uk of the time
was a very uncertain place
nevertheless lower staff taught me that
it's possible to have a good time
even when it rains and odd as it sounds
in this leisure obsessed era
that a holiday with a shared sense of
purpose
with activities and community can be
more relaxing
than merely hanging out by a pool
the campaign for the rebirth of the
holiday camp
starts here that was steve morris and
finally
toby young i started a dating site last
sunday
not words i ever thought i'd write but
i've become a kind of den mother
to a large group of people who believe
the risk of coronavirus has been
exaggerated
and it dawned on me that this could be a
useful service for them
the idea is that if you're a coveted
realist you don't want to go out with a
hysteric
who thinks the lockdown is being eased
too quickly and frets about a second
wave
you probably wouldn't even be able to
arrange a first date let alone manage a
kiss
at the end of the evening what you need
is a safe space
where you can meet potential partners
who share similar views
it all began in april when i started a
blog called lockdown skeptics
i wanted to create a clubhouse for that
small band of dissenters
who think that locking down the entire
population the healthy as well as the
sick
is a violation of our civil liberties
particularly when our scientific
understanding of how the virus is
transmitted
is so incomplete it quickly started
getting a lot of traffic
suggesting we aren't such a tiny
minority after all
on an average day the site gets 25 000
visitors
and to date it's had more than two and a
half million page views
last week i got an email from one of my
regular correspondents
saying he was newly divorced and
thinking of signing up with a dating
agency
quote it made me realize that a key
criterion for meeting someone
is that they absolutely must be a
lockdown skeptic he wrote
i genuinely think that if i can find a
girl as skeptical as me
she must therefore be marriage material
that's how important
and sadly divisive this issue has now
become
i could never date let alone build a
relationship with
a lockdown zealot unquote
that's when the light bulb appeared
above my head why not start a dating
site myself
my tech savvy collaborator ian ross had
already created some discussion forums
on the website
so all he needed to do was add a new
page where users could post their lonely
hearts messages
we decided to call it love in a covert
climate
almost as soon as it was launched it was
invaded by pro-lockdown trolls
who think anyone who downplays the
threat of the virus is a middle-aged
brexit-supporting
tory-voting scientifically illiterate 5g
conspiracy theorist
they began to post satirical personal
ads some of which i have to admit
were quite funny quote after a
demoralizing divorce
i was like many reinvigorated by the
brexit movement
only to be let down by boris in this
masked debacle
wrote one looking for albion loving lady
35-50 who would be open to dressing up
as winston churchill
and spanking me with a cricket bat while
i sing land of hope and glory
no snowflakes need apply unquote
other wags suggested alternative names
for the new service including
two meters okay stupid and spreader
the general theme was that lockdown
skeptics are more likely to have the
virus than other people
making them extremely unappealing as
dating prospects
i even got an email from a journalist at
the guardian asking me to respond to the
charge
that the forum could spread coronavirus
and harm the individuals involved
but as we skeptics are fond of pointing
out almost no one has the virus anymore
many people wildly exaggerate the risk
for instance a poll published a couple
of weeks ago found that the public
believe
that seven percent of the uk population
has died of covid19
that's more than four and a half million
people in fact
the real number of covered fatalities in
britain is about forty five thousand
one percent of that according to
john ionides a stanford professor of
medicine
you're more likely to die in a road
traffic accident than you are of the
virus if you're
under 65. as i told the guardian
reporter
i've created my dating site for people
who are properly informed about the risk
and want to meet others who haven't
succumbed to what bernard henry levy
calls
psychotic delirium luckily
ian rons had already put a team of
moderators in place to keep the forums
clean and tidy
and they quickly went to work kicking
out the trolls
since then i'm happy to report it's
really taken off
with dozens of legitimate users now
posting bona fide messages
i have no doubt that within six months
we'll be celebrating our first
lockdown skeptics wedding that was toby
young and that's it for this week
i hope you enjoyed it and please send
any feedback to
podcast spectator dot co dot uk we
always
love hearing from our listeners and if
you any thoughts at all in our podcast
please do send them in thank you and
thanks to our producers and you
you